alors je vous ai dit je suis bavard
alors comme je suis bavard je vais
prendre une petite précaution qui est de
commencer par les conclusions c'est
normalement c'est tout à fait interdit
dans un devoir de philo
ben moi je vais faire un truc tout à
fait interdit du reste ça reste entre
nous même si c enregistrés j'ai eu six
en philo au bac
donc je vais commencer par la conclusion
la première conclusion c'est que quand
on parle de croissance économique
on parle de croissance de
l'approvisionnement énergétique et quand
l'approvisionnement énergétique on parle
de croissance économique donc monsieur
macron pas plus que monsieur fillon pas
plus que monsieur juppé pas plus que
monsieur montebourg pas plus que
monsieur mélenchon ne ferons en sorte
que le pib en france soit supérieure en
2022 à ce qu'il est en 2017
aucun ne pourra le faire à cause de ce
que je vais vous raconter maintenant
donc la question c'est pas voter pour
celui qui fera revenir la croissance et
votez pour celui qui saura le mieux
gérer un univers en contraction c'est
bien comme ça qu'il va falloir prendre
le problème
nonobstant tout ce qu'il a pu promettre
et ça n'arrange pas les choses qu'ils
promettent le la deuxième chose très
désagréable que je vais vous exposer ce
soir c'est que pour ceux d'entre vous
qui ont suivi des cours d'économie
oublier les cours d'économie il n'ya pas
d'élasticité prix volumes en ce qui
concerne l'énergie
dit autrement c'est pas parce qu'on n'a
plus que ça vaut moins cher et qui en a
moins que ça vaut plus cher
la marche pas comme ça d'accord c'est
très désagréable donc toutes les belles
fonctions avec vous savez le prix qui
baissent quand le volume augmente je
sais pas quoi bullshit
en ce qui concerne l'énergie bullshit la
troisième chose que je vais vous montrer
c'est que pour des raisons géologiques
et non pas à cause du de la volonté des
borloo kosciusko et autres dans les pays
de l' ocde pour des raisons géologiques
l'approvisionnement dans la zone des
pays dits riches ocde est contraint à la
baisse depuis 2007 et que c'est le
déclencheur direct de tous les troubles
économiques qu'on a connus depuis et
dans ma vision du monde des élections un
peu surprenante que nous avons connue en
2016 tout ça est lié
je vous rappelle également une petite
chose simple mais que je vais développer
aussi sait qu'historiquement il ya deux
siècles on était 100% vénère donc si on
est passé de 100 % vénère à 80% de
cochonneries de fossiles c'est bien
qu'ils avaient une raison et on va aussi
essayer de comprendre pourquoi
si c'était si simple de rester 100%
renner s'emmerde aurait pas aujourd'hui
à essayer d'y retourner
on serait resté là où en était un il y
aurait pas de problème le autre chose
que je vais vous montrer c'est que il
n'ya pas de miracle technologique pour
respecter l'accord de paris et que 2° c
monstrueusement excessif il faut le
faire
peut-être mais en tout cas le faire en
s'imaginant que c'est compatible avec la
hausse du pouvoir d'achat
jamais je parais toutes mes économies
contre celle de qui veut paris
transmissibles à mes enfants que c'est
rigoureusement impossible voilà je vous
dis je il ya qui a 300 personnes prêtes
à paris et dans la salle
pas de problème je prends les 300 paris
enfin dernier point qui se rapproche un
peu de ce que j'ai dit au dessus dans un
univers contraint augmenter ce qu'on a
coutume d'appeler le libéralisme
dit autrement la mise en concurrence
l'initiative des acteurs non coordonnées
etc ça accroît le bordel ça ne fait pas
baisser donc d'augmenter la libre
concurrence dans un monde en expansion
c'est parfait pour le consommateur sans
qu'on bute sur des limites physiques
augmentent et la mise en concurrence
dans un monde qui a des limites
physiques
c'est exactement l'inversé que ça fait
ça a trop le bordel je vous dis ça parce
que on a fondé l'europe sur l'idée qu'on
allait faire des choses ensemble pour ne
plus se battre
excellente idée et on est aujourd'hui en
train de confondre la fin et moyens la
fin c'était pas se battre le moyen ça a
été de faire du commerce est envahie
puisqu'on fait du commerce on va
libéraliser partout et aujourd'hui
l'europe confond la fin ne pas se taper
dessus avec le moyen qui ai je fait
sauter la concurrence partout et tout le
temps et c'est ça mon objectif ultime
est comme ça tout le monde est content
non si aujourd'hui on veut la paix il
faut faire l'exact inverse dans ce genre
d'affaires mon programme économique
idéal que je vous exposerai tout à fait
à la fin donc ce n'est pas de la
physique vous préviens ça c'est tout à
fait de l'idéologie angot inclut le fait
d'abord que si dès qu'on cherche à
violer la loi de conservation de
l'énergie où la règle de trois on se
vautre rat est aujourd'hui
tous les politiques que je connais en
première approximation cherche à faire
ça tous la deuxième chose qu'il faut
avoir en tête c'est que il n'est pas
légitime de défendre une approche
coûts-bénéfices en matière
d'environnement
dit autrement si je n'agis pas je vais
perdre trois points de pib alors que si
j'agis en perd que 0 foutaise aussi déjà
personne n'est capable de prévoir le pib
dans dix ans ils sont ça se saurait donc
les gens sont encore moins capable
il ya de bonnes raisons à ça tu reste
donc les gens sont encore moins capable
de savoir qui est la fraction du pib
qu'on peut perdre si l'environnement est
détériorée en fait si vous poussez le
raisonnement à son à son à la caricature
s'il ya plus d'environnements du tout je
suis pris de la planète terre est plus
de pib du tout donc une chose absolument
certaine c'est que sans environnement
n'y a pas de pays des donc combien de
pays des jeux perd 6 j'entame
l'environnement n'importe quoi entre 0
et 100 %
ça c'est une copie que j'accepte sinon
non et enfin ça signifie dans cet
univers en contraction donc que votre
pouvoir d'achat et lien va descendre
c'est bien ça qui va se passer
eh bien ça signifie que si on veut
continuer à donner des emplois aux gens
il faut passer d'un système qui pousse à
la consommation un système qui pousse à
la reconstruction
parce qu'en fait notre système
aujourd'hui notre notre mode de vie
il est totalement incompatible enfin on
peut pas maintenir la paix sociale dans
un contexte de décrue rapide des
combustibles fossiles avec les
infrastructures qui existent telles
qu'elles sont aujourd'hui ça marche pas
il ya trop de monde dans les bureaux pas
assez dans les champs et c'est tout a
pas de trucs et trop de monde dans les
villes par ac dans le tissu rural
bref ya tout un tas de trucs qui
organisait de travers si on veut
résister dans un cadre de paix sociale
et donc il faut tout reconstruire
et en fait les deux degrés en gros ça
vise à ça un service à tout reconstruire
voilà donc ça c'est les conclusions
maintenant ceux qui ont soif peuvent
partir et pour les autres on va rentrer
dans le vif du sujet